in honor of nora from queens and
aquafina being from queens i thought
that maybe we could play a little trivia
game to test how much you really know
about your hometown
your game
yeah okay i i really hope i know about
my hometown yeah it's a little game
we're calling queen of queens
[Applause]
now since i'm not from queens um i
thought you should play against another
true blue queens native please welcome
the legendary fran drescher
[Applause]
i can't believe i'm here right now
i love both you girls i'm so happy to be
included in this queen of queen's game
i love you so much i mean like i'm in a
queen of queensland i should be your
neighbor
on the show yes
we're setting the i'm setting the offer
right now the offer is coming
oh my god
maybe it's the love connection that
we're playing
aquatina from queens i mean you're
carrying the torch girl and i'm really
really thrilled oh
thank you where where
do can we break away from where
in queens are you
flush are you
you're from flushing that's crazy did
you go to did you go to alums
of course that's where my sister's sweet
16 was
[Applause]
you know fran i was reading something
that you said once is it true that like
one television executive said to you
like your voice i don't know
and then another person was like it's
because of you your voice your
personality that this is gonna work
yes actually you know i i mean all along
the road people said that the voice was
going to hold me back and it was peter
jacobson my writing producing partner
and my beloved gay ex-husband
who said uh-uh that's you know the voice
the face the comic timing that's what's
gonna make you a star and we're gonna
lean into it
we're not gonna try and dilute it or
move away from it
and and he was right you know i'm really
grateful but back in the day when we had
sold the idea for the show
they actually said can the character be
italian and not jewish right
and uh
yeah
we said now that you know we couldn't
write it as authentically i i know how
to be jewish we know how to write jewish
that's the way we have to go and i kind
of just even though i knew it was my big
break we said
you know no because i don't i don't like
to have regret and i thought if i go
along with this idiotic suggestion and
it doesn't fly i'm going to be kicking
myself why did i listen to them so you
know i just kind of make it a cardinal
rule that i go with my god and i try and
convince everybody why i think it's the
right idea
rather than
play please well i thank you both for
putting out shows
authentic to who you are
and changing the world to welcome other
people to find that confidence and do
the same so thank you for that thank you
thank
you and
so your origin story starts in queens
we're going to play a game you guys are
going to take turns answering
questions with multiple choice options
and the person with the most correct
answers wins the queen of queens let's
get to it the first question goes to
aquafina aquafina what famous magician
is buried in a cemetery in queens is it
a
david copperfield b william ellsworth
robinson c
magicians can't always be put in a box
they can escape
or d harry houdini i want to say houdini
but i feel like it might be copperfield
or the or c
oh god they're going to come the
magicians are going to come after me the
magicians are going to come houdini you
okay with terry houdini
okay houdini interior
[Applause]
oh look she's got crowns falling from
the sky okay fran what neighborhood of
queens did cindy lauper grow up in was
it ozone park
a b jackson heights c girls just want to
have flushing or d sunnyside
[Applause]
[Music]
which one of these people
of note was not born in queens a howard
stern b tony danza c laurie laughlin or
d al roker
oh oh man
i almost want to say
howard stern
but
i don't know i don't know can i can i
have a lifeline can i take a lifeline
forget can i take it for a friend what
do you think what do you think it is
i think your first instincts are right
i'm gonna say how it's turned
well you'll both be interested to know
it's b tony danza he was not born in
queens
oh he was born in brooklyn
okay friends turn which subway line runs
through queens a the six train b the d
train c the a train d idk
i'm gonna guess the d
the a train goes to queens
i apparently
okay it does it goes
all right this score is high a while
since i've taken the subway you know
i've been stuck in a train car
with fans there's no way out you know
no yeah no yeah okay last question goes
to aquafina what part of queens did the
nanny take place in a astoria b forest
hills c
flushing d dresher island
let's see right yes yes
[Applause]
the flashy girl from flushing the nanny
named friend
well the accumulative winner is aquafina
today
but you are both
queens two amazing queens who have
changed the world
three queens three queens
and fran drescher i am so honored to be
in your queen's sandwich right now
and
may we all be able to come together
again as soon as possible nora from
queens wednesdays at 10 9 central on
comedy central
[Music]